[Musique]
sensation sensation le mag
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur sensation
en association avec TV 78 je suis
aujourd'hui avec Philippe Corda adjoint
à la mairie de plaisir délégué à la
culture pour tous on va parler ensemble
du lancement des classes à horaires
aménagé théâtre pour chat bonjour
bonjour alors vous êtes donc élus à la
culture dans la commune de plaisir la
culture pour tous qui propose cette
année une formation artistique aux
élèves du collège Blaise Pascal pourquoi
vouloir ouvrir ce genre de formation au
collégien et quelle est la jeunesse de
ce de ce projet écoutez ça fait déjà
maintenant quatre ans que les élèves du
collège Blaise Pascal peuvent profiter
de cette formation c'est une formation
qui fait partie du cursus qui a été mise
en place avec l'Éducation nationale on
avait souhaité puisque la ville de
Plaisir est assez je dirais valorisante
au niveau de la culture en général et
des arts en général aussi du coup l'idée
était de proposer des élèves qui avaient
montré des motivations une certaine
appétence au théâtre
sans doute également vouloir un peu
tester avant de s'engager peut-être aux
conservatoire si la suite les intéresse
et on a commencé une première année par
la sixième l'année d'après ils sont
passés en 5ème ils ont souhaité
continuer ce cursus et ainsi de suite et
puis là maintenant de 3 de la 6e à la
quatrième à la cinquième à la troisième
tous les classes sont remplis et on
prolonge donc avec une nouvelle
convention pour l'année prochaine il y
avait donc finalement une demande aussi
de la part des élèves finalement d'avoir
un accès à cet art du spectacle oui en
fait je pense que c'est un mix à la fois
de la proviseur du collège qui était
assez promotrice aussi du du sujet les
élèves qui avaient fait des appels du
pied des professeurs aussi qui étaient
intéressés et puis le conservatoire qui
vous le savez peut-être s'implique aussi
dans les écoles élémentaires en venant
donner une petite sensibilisation aux
arts du théâtre et peut-être que
certains élèves s'en souvenaient et ont
souhaité continuer à apprendre quelque
chose autour de l'art vivant vers les
élèves du collège Blaise Pascal peuvent
s'inscrire à poursuivre cette formation
artistique comment est-ce que cette
formation va justement s'intégrer avec
avec les autres cours et où se feront
les cours de théâtre alors les cours de
théâtre vont se faire principalement au
collège comme les autres cours mais
puisqu'on est en partenariat avec la clé
des champs et avec le théâtre Coluche de
la ville de plaisir ils pourront assez
vite aussi venir répéter ou tester telle
ou tel spectacle dans nos murs et l'idée
c'est de les ouvrir aussi un petit peu
au spectacle vivant en règle générale
donc je pense qu'il y a des sorties
aussi qui sont organisées pour aller
voir d'autres spectacles pourquoi pas 50
ans en Yvelines par exemple mais il faut
pas nécessairement avoir justement des
des compétences ou avoir déjà fait du
théâtre pour suivre cette formation non
alors en fait bien sûr il y a une
période d'observation où on regarde un
petit peu comment les élèves se
comportent vis-à-vis de ce cette
composante théâtre il y a une commission
qui se réunit qui il est challenge un
petit peu qui teste surtout leur
motivation non c'est pas une notion de
compétence initiale c'est plutôt
vraiment une appétence une motivation
que l'on retient justement parler des
bénéfices d'une formation artistique
c'est le conservatoire de plaisir vous
l'avez dit qu'il sera en charge de
former les élèves la formation est en
partenariat avec la clé des champs et le
théâtre Coluche de salle de spectacle
donc de plaisir comment le projet a-t-il
été perçu justement par les directeurs
et directrices des deux salles alors ils
sont bien sûr tout à fait promoteurs de
l'idée puisque par principe ils ne sont
pas que simples directeur de structure
de diffusion musicale ils sont en charge
de projet culturels au sens général du
terme souvent transverse souvent en
coopération d'ailleurs avec entre eux
mais également avec l'Éducation
nationale ou des associations de la
ville de plaisir qui pourraient aussi
avoir des sujets d'intérêt commun et
donc bien sûr ils sont non seulement
promoteurs mais ils accueillent les
élèves à bras ouverts et l'idée c'est
également aussi de profiter de leur la
programmation pour peut-être commencer à
les alors demandé
ce qu'ils ont pensé de la programmation
du dernier spectacle auquel ils ont
assisté les mettre à peut-être en
position de critique aussi pour
commencer à s'interroger eux-mêmes sur
ce qui les intéresse quand ils vont au
spectacle il y a pas simplement
finalement la pratique du théâtre dans
dans ses cours mais il y a aussi en tout
cas dans votre volonté le fait d'avoir
un regard critique justement sur les
pièces qui vont voir sur les œuvres oui
oui c'est ça c'est la découverte en
règle générale des arts vivants et puis
de s'interroger un petit peu sur sa
propre motivation ce qui nous intéresse
qui nous intéresse moins peut-être
rencontrer des comédiens ou d'émetteurs
en scène lors de projets transverses et
puis si je dirais le sujet les convaincs
le conservatoire est à leur disposition
pour compléter cette formation par un
cursus pleines et entier puisque on
bénéficie sur la ville de plaisir d'un
troisième cycle qui permet la
professionnalisation et on a quelques
élèves comme ça chaque année qui
continue leur cours à Paris et qui
deviennent des comédiens professionnels
par le projet a déjà quelques années
vous l'avez dit il y a un instant quel
est le bilan justement que vous faites
de de ces premières années de de de donc
c'est ça s'appelle le chat c'est ça le
classe à horaires aménagé
ou pour d'autres disciplines artistiques
donc écoutez on a déjà quatre promotions
entre guillemets on a on leur a proposé
de venir participer à des événements de
la ville par exemple il y avait la nuit
du conservatoire qui s'est déroulée là
il y a quelques semaines ils sont venus
présenter une pièce
tout à fait spontanément il y a eu aussi
une petite période de flash mob à
l'hôtel de ville où ils sont venus
déclamer quelques échanges comme ça très
très spontanément très très
sympathiquement et donc l'idée c'est de
continuer à promouvoir ça et à les
inclure dans les activités culturelles
de la ville donc il y a une cinquantaine
d'élèves là qui sont concernés quand
même donc ça commence à prendre forme
et on sait que certains continueront au
lycée puisque le lycée a aussi une
classe théâtre alors pas dans le même
contexte mais qui peut tout à fait faire
la suite et faire le lien jusqu'au comme
je le disais tout à l'heure le troisième
cycle du Conservatoire donc à la fois
cette formation peut permettre justement
aux élèves de suivre encore un cursus
après le collège ça va pas s'arrêter
justement la fin de la troisième ça peut
se poursuivre au lycée et après dans des
classes aussi préparatoires exactement
et c'est notre fierté à plaisir d'avoir
depuis de la sensibilisation dans les
écoles primaires par les professeurs du
conservatoire jusqu'au troisième cycle
de ce fameux conservatoire en passant
par les classes horaire ménagées du
collège et puis la classe théâtre du
lycée voilà alors le théâtre fait rêver
transmet des messages vous permet une
parenthèse dans notre quotidien de
nombreux acteurs estiment également que
le théâtre est bénéfique pour la
confiance en soi ou la prise de parole
par exemple alors est-ce que ce sont
également ces bénéfices qui ont animé ce
désir d'ouvrir le chat aux élèves de de
du collège de plaisir alors certes
certainement quand on regarde
nos amis anglo-saxons on voit que le
cursus d'éloquence fait partie de
beaucoup de d'écoles ce qui est
peut-être moins le cas en France donc
sans doute que certains professeurs en
profitent pour apporter un support sur
ce plan-là peut-être que certains élèves
l'ont choisi spontanément mais je crois
que vraiment ce qui les intéresse c'est
tout simplement de participer à une
expérience théâtrale originale et en
fait peut-être de se projeter par
rapport à ce qu'ils ont pu voir en
allant au spectacle avec leurs amis ou
avec leurs parents justement un petit
débat autour de cette de cette culture
et de la jeunesse notamment le
gouvernement et même les Yvelines
essayent de d'intéresser la jeunesse et
de mettre en place des dispositifs pour
un peu plus intéresser la jeunesse à la
à la culture et au théâtre est-ce que
vous vous estimez justement que le
théâtre doit trouver un plus grand
intérêt dans la jeunesse oui alors c'est
pas pour rien que ma délégation
s'appelle la culture pour tous on a on a
l'ambition avec notre mère Joséphine
Coleman berger qui vous vous avez très
impliqué sur le milieu culturel
puisqu'elle est vice-présidente à la
culture au département
on souhaite effectivement aller au
devant des jeunes dans les quartiers qui
seraient pas spécialement enclin à venir
spontanément au théâtre ou même un
spectacle musical à la clé des champs
par exemple et donc avec les directeurs
de ces structures et avec les pôles
jeunesse de la ville on a pour ambition
d'aller proposer quelques initiatives
dans les quartiers pour détecter les
jeunes talents peut-être leur proposer
des activités dans leur quartier pour
qu'après spontanément ils aient envie de
venir en savoir plus en venant dans
notre salle de spectacle et pourquoi pas
dans les classes adaptées et qu'est-ce
qu'on peut vous souhaiter justement dans
la suite de ce projet pour son évolution
bah écoutez que ça se répande que on
profite plus en plus de du spectacle
vivant sur la ville de plaisir mais
également plus largement dans notre
agglomération de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines puisqu'on a la
chance d'avoir une scène nationale on a
d'autres activités culture plus
importante au sein de notre
agglomération donc on a aussi l'ambition
d'avoir peut-être des partenariats un
petit peu plus larges avec nos villes
cette communauté de communes et puis
avoir des projets transverses qui
permettraient aux jeunes de s'y
retrouver finalement assez spontanément
assez naturellement autour de du
spectacle vivant et l'idée c'est ça
c'est de pérenniser finalement et de
faire évoluer donc pas seulement la
ville de plaisir mais à tous 50 ans en
Yvelines au finalement
dans la mesure du possible on élargit à
tous merci beaucoup Philippe Corda
d'avoir été avec nous sur sensation
alors rapidement les élèves pourront
également présenter finalement un
spectacle aux parents ou même aux
personnes qui voudraient voir leur
travail oui alors on profite toujours
d'un événement de la ville pour leur
positionner un petit créneau où ils
peuvent s'exprimer donc voilà ça fait
partie des traditions et les parents
peuvent être assurés ils verront leurs
élèves progressés et Ben et puis on
pourra en parler en parler ensemble dans
une autre émission merci beaucoup
Philippe Corda d'avoir été avec nous sur
sensation on peut retrouver plus
d'informations sur le site ville
.fr et pour revoir ou réécouter cette
émission rendez-vous sur notre site et
notre application radio sensation
[Musique]